applications you take to win you're  still in this  no i think magnus just wanted to have  more fun that's it yeah yeah i mean okay  this b5 window is unnecessary i think he  just wanted to have fun and try to beat  me  well still i mean you are now still  pushing to become number two in this  tournament that is important isn't it  yeah  it's important sort of but i in the  opening i just kind of uh  um i was still upset about the previous  games i was just blitzing out the most  which was just bad i just got a  completely bad position out of the  opening and okay it's just after that  you you played this b5 and  that means you already have practice you  can now go and blitz more moves  but those are bad so  good luck thanks